all right the president delivered of
soaring first State of the Union address
almost 50 million Americans watched last
night and by the way by far more people
watch the Fox News Channel we really
want to say thank you so much for
trusting us we want to earn that trust
every day now the speech highlighted the
president's many accomplishments and he
touted how it is he is now enacting
Reagan's style conservative principles
and they're working now of course the
vast majority of Democrats led by
negative Nancy Pelosi they hated every
single second of it and it was obvious
and they sat on their hands with a scowl
on their face refusing to applaud things
you would think they'd want to applaud
historically low unemployment in the
country now just take a look at some of
the examples of the Democrats just
playing petty partisan politics take a
look we are finally seeing rising wages
african-american unemployment stands at
the lowest rate ever recorded
hispanic-american unemployment has also
reached the lowest levels in history
[Applause]
all right we're gonna have born the
Democrats ridiculous behavior that's
coming up later in the show you see the
left in America they have no ideas they
have no solutions they don't stand for
anything except they're against
President Trump they hate President
Trump now congressman Lewis gatir has
even walked out of the speech during
chants of USA USA and his excuse oh he
had to get ready for an interview White
House press secretary Sarah Sanders is
calling out Pelosi and the Democrats
with some really really powerful truth
take a look I think Nancy Pelosi looks
like that all the time I think she
should smile a lot more often I think
the country would be better for it she
seems to kind of embody the bitterness
that belongs in the Democrat Party right
now I think last night was a good step
forward hopefully they can let go of
some of that and they have to make a big
decision they need to decide Chris do
they love America more than they hate
this president and are they willing to
put some of those differences aside come
together and do what's right for this
country now wouldn't that be great what
it's rific won't come together fix the
country help the Forgotten men and women
well will Democrats ever put the country
before the hatred of the president
interesting question upon them now we
have our doubts remember they supported
eight years of Obama's failure we had 13
million more Americans on food stamps
eight million more in poverty the lowest
labor participation rate since the 70s
the worst economic recovery since the
40s the lowest home ownership rate in 51
years and Obama accumulated more debt
than every other president before him
combined and he was the only president
never to reach 3% GDP growth in the
course of his presidency in any one
given year and then you have the liberal
mainstream media they are in full
breakdown freakout mode over the
president's successful State of the
Union address you can't make this up
their bias is so transparent what you
saw tonight was President Trump I think
and with one hand reaching out his hand
to Democrats and with the other hand
holding up a fist the president met with
me after the speech I would say to him
well that was how not to give a unifying
speech again sort of stoking I think
many would say racial tensions by
bringing up this issue of kneeling
I think his rhetoric last night set
things back the way he sold immigration
really offended a lot of Democrats that
were listening in that room if that was
an attempt at unity he's got a lot of
work to do I go through these things
especially these teleprompter speeches
he gives it's not him
but you could tell he's reading it he
doesn't own it he was selling sweet
tasting candy with poison in it it
revealed Donald Trump's deep and almost
sort of sad obsession with being like
you tell me it's supposed to respond
like this to the Great Dictator no but
they're not supposed to sit on their
hands really all right and that's not
all the whole network fake news CNN they
went on full-on conspiratorial mode
about the color of the First Lady
Melania Trump's outfit now the
speculation is an utter disgrace but
sadly very predictable let's take a look
is there anything you tell us about her
outfit you know she's wearing a cream
colored suit there which I find
interesting remember last year the
female Democratic senators all wore
white a bunch of them to protest Trump's
policies against women so if there was
even a hashtag women wear white listen
it could be a total coincidence but I
just find a lot of the stuff she does
these days to look at it twice and NBC
News they can't give up their obsession
with the quote Russia investigation even
moments before the State of the Union
this - a disgrace watch this is a
president who's under criminal
investigation right now for obstruction
of justice with regard to the Russian
investigation so a lot going on in the
backdrop there is a missing majors
in this fall tonight that we ought not
to forget about and that is the special
prosecutor of the United States who is
at this hour probably meeting with his
team it's not out there
he sort of hovers Oh hide the chain
investor that is a extraordinarily
important part of what's going on in
Washington DC an abject lesson this
shows you just how completely out of
touch the liberal mainstream destroyed
Trump media really is it didn't matter
what the president said last night the
media had already predetermined that
they were going to hate it but of course
you the American people you had a very
different reaction to the State of the
Union let's look at the CBS News poll
seventy five percent of people who watch
they approved of the president speech
and even fake news the whole network CNN
their polls show that combined 70
percent of speech watchers they had a
positive reaction now if you just watch
the media's hysterical coverage you
wouldn't know any of this and you
probably even think that everybody hated
this speech that's why on this program
we call them the destroy Trump media now
also important breaking news this hour
we have massive developments regarding
the release of the four-page classified
memo exposing Obama era surveillance of
members of the Trump campaign and the
Trump transition and sources are telling
me tonight that there is an internal
debate at the White House about whether
they should release the memo with other
supporting documents and I for one and
for full transparency release it all and
I don't really want anything redacted we
maybe if it impacts sources and methods
and security only make the memo public
and by the way it's about getting the
truth out and that is scaring the living
hell out of some people at the FBI and
the DOJ tonight and of course the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein and of
course Peter struck now according to The
Daily Beast Rosenstein he's named in
that memo and according to other
reporting the Deputy Attorney General is
responsible for extending the FISA
warrant to literally spy on Trump
campaign manager remember the pretext
was all under quarter-page they went
much further and clearly Rosenstein is
shaking in his boots tonight now we're
hearing from sources that he is the most
scared individual in Washington right
now
and at this point it's all about
self-preservation for him now just look
at what fake news CNN is reporting
tonight the President Trump asked
Rosenstein if he was on his team now
someone might want to check Rosenstein
phone records and emails because isn't
it a little too convenient that when the
walls begin to close in on him
especially after McCabe being fired all
of a sudden there's a targeted leak to
make Rosen Stein look better the FBI is
also trying to attack the memo and Peter
struck he's trying to distract away from
his own scandals by selectively leaking
information to CNN to try and make
himself look better now Sarah Carter who
will join us in a little bit as
reporting tonight that the US
intelligence agencies are joining the
effort to block the memo from being
released they don't want us to see it
they don't want you to see it
you have liberal Senator Cory Booker is
saying releasing the memo would be quote
treasonous and in a statement earlier
the FBI wrote in part quote with regard
to the house intelligence committees
memorandum the FBI was provided a
limited opportunity to review this memo
the day before the committee voted to
release it as expressed during our
initial interview we have grave concerns
about material omissions of fact that
fundamentally impact the memos accuracy
so today the FBI they are trying to take
shots of the memo but yesterday our own
catherine herridge reported this to
senior FBI officials that reviewed the
memo quote could not point to any
factual inaccuracies now the House
Intelligence Committee chairman Devin
Nunez he's firing back with a powerful
statement of his own here's what he said
and it's very revealing
having stonewall Congress's demands for
information for nearly a year it's no
surprise to see the FBI and DOJ issue
spurious objections to allowing the
American people to see information
related to surveillance abuses at these
agencies the FBI is intimately familiar
with material omissions with respect to
their presentations to both Congress and
the courts and they are welcome to make
public to the greatest extent possible
all the information they have on these
abuses regardless it's clear that top
officials used unverified information
in a court document to fuel a
counterintelligence investigation during
an American political campaign once this
truth gets out or we can begin taking
steps to ensure our intelligence
agencies and courts are never misused
like this again
now it makes perfect sense the FBI we
try to tear down or D legitimize that
memo because the memo clearly according
to Devin Nunez exposes top ranking
officials at the bureau using it
unverified clinton bought and paid for
dossier as we have been telling you as
in part the justification to spy on an
opposition campaign during an election
and a president-elect and his team now
to be clear the media will never report
this what I'm talking about
rank-and-file members who work every
single day at the FBI the DOJ and the
intelligence community what we're
talking about and we're very specific
are a few bad actors in those
communities that are on the verge of
being exposed for committing massive
constitutional violations now that's why
they're desperately trying to prevent
the memo from coming out from you having
an opportunity to see it he may remember
back in January after almost a year of
stonewalling
devyn newness and the house Intel
committee well we know that rod
Rosenstein and FBI director Christopher
Rae they went crawling into speaker Paul
Ryan's office begging at the last hour
after a year don't give the House
Intelligence Committee access to the
Russia investigation related documents
Nunez had to threaten to hold them in
contempt before they would comply and
thankfully to speaker Ryan's credit he
held his ground in that meeting now if
they did nothing wrong if they didn't do
anything wrong then why fights so hard
to prevent Congress from seeing the
documents she released the memo released
the underlying documents with it the
documentation of it all and if they did
nothing wrong well then they were trying
to why they trying to stop the memo from
coming out what don't top FBI and DOJ
officials want you the American people
to know this is an important question
we're heading towards a showdown